peu
je suis navré monsieur je ne peux pas
vous laisser entrer d'un certain pour
une part sur l'initiation et pourquoi je
comprends pas c'est une enceinte
réservée aux francs maçons
rien de ce qui se passe ici on pourrait
vous intéresser on peut pas être témoin
une amazone ring pour la vivre elle est
un communiqué à mon plan intellectuel
[Musique]
oh
beaucoup
trou mais faire une très respectable
formelle accompagné de ses grands
officiers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
respectable frères remporté grève
veillez je vous prie remplir votre
office
[Applaudissements]
respectable frais à grand porte étendard
veillée placer notre bannière à lorient
mes frères
veuillez prendre place mes frères
veuillez prendre place
[Musique]
mais cei
initiez vous à moi pour ouvrir les
travaux avant d'ouvrir les travaux
invoquant la protection du grand
architecte de l'univers sur toutes nos
entreprises puissent nos travaux ouverts
ainsi dans l'ordre se continuer dans la
paix et se terminer dans l'harmonie
ainsi soit il je vais demande maintenant
demandé aux représentants de la
télévision française c'est-à-dire
d'antenne 2 de bien vouloir se retirer
cette cérémonie d'ouverture ne pouvant
être pratiqué que devant des francs
maçons
[Musique]
nous côtoyons des francs-maçons chaque
jour dans toutes les circonstances de la
vie
dans la majorité des cas on ignore leur
qualité maçonnique
ils tiennent secrète toutes les classes
sociales toutes les professions se
retrouve au sein de la maçonnerie
si l'on considère la répartition
socioprofessionnelle du grand orient
on constate une majorité absolue de 60 %
de représentants de la fonction publique
les salariés du secteur privé ne
représentent que 25% des effectifs avec
une très grande majorité de cadres
moyens et supérieurs
les ouvriers ne sont que quelques
exceptions par contre les professions
libérales sont très largement
représentées
pardon monsieur ce que vous pourriez
nous dire ce qu'est le grand orient de
france
monza effigie temps je connais rien du
tout entier j'ai pas l'instruction et je
sais pas lire et écrire
qu'est ce que c'est la franc maçonnerie
ça c'est un petit peu de tout à
apprendre à 110 un petit peu de sens si
bon moi je trouve que c'est plutôt la
bourgeoisie il ya pas mal d'argent
c'est un petit peu les sons familiers
quelques maçons ont accepté de se
montrer à visage découvert
[Musique]
que faisiez-vous dans l'église je répète
vos liens parce que je suis comédienne
sera fait plus que pour le marais et
donc c'est ma vie profane et pour ma vie
spirituelle bien je suis mason
normalement une mason et excommunie elle
a pas leur entourage une église au c'est
une vieille histoire qui sont les trois
mâts sont socialement ou en général
socialement celui des petits bourgeois
je crois j'encadre même un peu plus
docteur qu'est-ce qui vous incitent
devenir maçon vous me posez cette
question en tant que médecin ou en tant
que comme en tant qu'homme en tant
qu'individu je pense que il n'ya pas de
différence fondamentale d'un homme à un
autre
la franc maçonnerie est un lieu de
rencontre et voyez vous au faux si les
uns et les autres sont restés un peu en
deçà de ce qu'ils auraient pu faire si
les messins n'ont pas mis assez l'accent
sur la prévention
si les formations n'ont pas su inculquer
un sens civique aussi fort que celui
qu'on peut constater dans d'autres pays
où la franc maçonnerie impératif c'est
peut-être que justement il n'y avait pas
assez et de médecins et franc maçon en
france au cours du siècle dernier
monsieur laval pourquoi bâtisse et vous
des temples pourquoi êtes-vous redevenu
un maçon opératif c'est une aventure qui
remonte à quelques applis un peu plus de
trente ans j'ai été déporté comme
beaucoup de citoyens qui ont cru qu il
fallait le faire et j'avais j'avais dans
mon bloc un prêtre extrêmement
sympathique qui en atten me dis tiens
que ce tanoh une grande nouvelle
qu'est ce qui se passe durant de
nouvelles du seppuku sa tuile très pas
beaucoup et me dit oui si j'en sors
des vrais chapelle naude est sans doute
à la vierge lui et coutumes donne une
idée moi j'ai pas de vierge à ces
terrains mais c'est sûr que si je sors
ferait quelque chose pour la maçonnerie
effectivement j'ai construit cette
maison et j'ai construit un temps que
l'on pensait bien sûr ce que j'ai voulu
faire c'est le sait le temps j'ai
terminé en 64 c'est à dire 18 ans de
travail le temple intérieure celle
amende
le reste est de noyau et celui ci va
vous prendre alors celui ci je vais
commencer il y a un an et demi et je
m'assigne un an pour le terminer et
suffit j'étais dans l'obligation de le
construire pour avoir ici le complexe
maçonnique les moyens le mot est
horrible mode push mais pour avoir pour
pouvoir ici tenir n'importe quelle tenue
à n'importe quel degré du 1er au 33e de
rage me fait tenir
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font les francs
maçons sont des jeunes qui oeuvrent je
pense pour l'homme en particulier pour
la liberté pour l'humanisme c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui rend service
à certaines personnes et à mon avis qui
peut être néfaste parce qu'au fond c'est
serait parti d'une certaine ma fille à
la grande loge de france possède une
forte implantation en province plus de
100 loges disséminés aux quatre coins de
l'hexagone
chaque mois les délégués des régions
viennent informer le conseil fédéral
les activités maçonnique de la province
faire représente une portion de ce
territoire et des loges qui seront
situées tant que soul et moi je vais me
cantonner à ce qui se passe dans une
ville où je suis le représentant conseil
fédéral marseille les temps sont révolus
on l'aimé soit on se taisait
ils sont connus ils ont pignon sur rue
par exemple vous avez à ces renforts il
ya 1 % de francs maçons dans la
population saint tropez aussi d'évident
ya beaucoup de noms de l'été mais leur
l'hiver tout le monde se connaît nous
venons de créer à draguignan une loge
mozart nous avons reçu le ciri nissim
aux grands maîtres qui a fait une
conférence formidable qui a intéressé
tout le monde est difficile de se cacher
l'est est en pleine expansion depuis
quelques années mais actuellement des
loges se crée de plus en plus nombreuses
le maçon considère à l'heure actuelle
que il n'a pas plus de raison de cacher
ou de 2,2 de ne pas faire état de ses
convictions sur le plan spirituel de sa
qualification spirituel que les tenants
des grandes religions connu jusqu'à
présent
en ce qui concerne lyon lyon vous le
savez est une ville de tradition
ésotérique et par conséquent où les
chapelles sont nombreuses dans la maison
du grand architecte
malheureusement la franc maçonnerie
lyonnaise n'est pas ce qu'elle devrait
être
néanmoins je dois dire que il y a
maintenant de plus en plus de gens qui
viennent à nous et qui viennent
ouvertement à nous bien parfois
ceci pour l'anecdote de très hauts
fonctionnaires
dans ma vie je connais qui ne
fréquentent pas ma loge parce qu'ils ne
tiennent pas être découvert et qui vont
à paris je ne pense pas sentir le soufre
périgueux et je ne pense pas que nous
fassions père je vous dis on a essayé
démystifier je crois que nous y sommes
arrivés
mais toutefois des gens ne nous
connaissent pas je pense que il est bon
qu'on nous connaisse les catholiques ont
compris maintenant que la franc
maçonnerie n'était pas tellement leurs
ennemis et l'oecuménisme moderne je
crois que c'est valable pour le marre je
suis élue socialiste je suis conseiller
municipal et conseiller de la communauté
jamais dans une campagne électorale les
forces de droite non dits untel untel
untel et formation jamais les gens
disent moi il est franc maçon les
formations et pourtant alors au début on
attendait tout de même quelques fois la
réflexion des francs-maçons tiens c'est
bizarre c'est un brave homme la franc
maçonnerie est un ordre universel
elle est présente sur les cinq
continents dans tous les pays du monde à
l'exception des pays ayant un régime à
caractère totalitaire
il existe des fédérations de loges
maçonniques réunis en grande loge ou en
grand orient
la franc maçonnerie et plus
particulièrement présente dans les pays
anglo-saxons et ceux ayant subi leur
influence de pays à pays les grandes
loges entretiennent entre elles des
relations quasi diplomatique dans chaque
grande loge on trouve un grand
chancelier charge les relations
internationales
messieurs je suis heureux de vous
accueillir et nous sommes réunis pour
faire un peu le point de nos affaires
sur le plan international parler des
relations maçonnique avec le tiers-monde
de la présence maçonnique notamment en
afrique
je vous rappelle très en gros qui lie
actuellement dans le monde 200
obédiences maçonniques environ 606
millions 600 mille masson près de 70000
loges et que le grand orient de france a
une présence internationale il est
présente dans une trentaine d'endroits
dans le monde
ce régime de m plusieurs facteurs des
divisions et d'affrontement bouleverse
l'afrique
la franc maçonnerie est elle capable de
restaurer et de coaguler la confiance
nécessaire à la collaboration efficace
quand il y a
des maçons soucieux de l'intérêt général
des institutions
eh bien nous avons acheté une forme d'
équilibre dans la cité deux ministres
masson se disputeront peut-être pour
avoir un poste différent mais croyez moi
au pied du mur ils n'oseront pas situer
nous avons constaté que les églises on
parcourt est en quelque sorte la culture
en portant un coup dur en occultant
l'occurrence le culte du veau tout or la
maçonnerie prêche la liberté de
conscience
penses-tu que des africains à maçon
peuvent utiliser les techniques
rationnelle de la franc maçonnerie pour
approfondir leurs recherches et leurs
retours sur la source
à côté stablement n'est ce pas puisque
la maçonnerie a pour ambition d'être un
carrefour
elle est le centre de l'union comme dit
le vieux textes de 1723 elle reconnaît à
chacun l'absolue liberté de conscience
ce que nous voulons c'est faire
collaborer les hommes les faire
travailler ensemble dans le respect de
toutes leurs croyances philosophie ou
avis et au niveau de l'afrique on sent
très bien qu un large chemin s'en trouve
c'est pourquoi souvent nous nous
demandons même si les rites africain
futur maçonnique ne devront pas être
propre à vos pays
l'uimm insérer des cimes grand maître
les africains peuvent s'étonner que
après nos indépendances politiques il y
a toujours en afrique des ateliers
administrativement dépendant des grandes
obédiences d'europe
que pensez-vous de l'africanisation la
franc maçonnerie 7 africanisation de la
franc-maçonnerie arrivera mais il faut
considérer le développement de la
maçonnerie africaine un peu comme un
investissement que l'on investit dans
les usines ont investi dans les écoles
si vous voulez investir dans la
tolérance
il faut le savoir et à ce moment là il
faut donc bâtir le projet former des
hommes et construire vos propres
maçonnerie en conclusion voyez-vous
monsieur je crois que ce qui est
important c'est que dans notre travail
maçonnique
nous touchons là aussi l'un des aspects
des relations entre l'europe et
l'afrique
je crois qu'il y aura d'ici dix ans une
grande politique maçonnique
quant aux relations euro africaine
pour faciliter les contacts de leurs
membres voyageant à l'étranger les
grande loge nationale des livres à
chacun un document maçonnique qui est en
réalité un passeport grâce à un tel
document même aux antipodes un frère est
assuré de trouver bon accueil auprès des
maçons locaux et bien non la grande loge
de france et mes qualités devant
chancelier je suis très heureux de
recevoir mexique ici ainsi lors grande
loge respectives se reconnaissent ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas
la franc maçonnerie société discrète ne
recrute pas ouvertement les maçons
identifie et contacts dans la société
ce qu'il juge dignes d'apporter une
contribution efficace à l'édification du
temps toutefois à l'occasion de
colloques de journées d'études
organisées pour mieux faire connaître
leurs travaux les obédiences maçonniques
françaises laissent entrer le public
dans leur temps cela s'appelle une tenue
blanche ouverte
c'est à dire ouverte aux profanes ceux
qui viennent là sont soit des
sympathisants soit des curieux et
certains de futurs maçons ce jour-là à
la grande loge de france
le public était convié dans le grand
temps
[Musique]
le collège des officiers de la
respectable loge kheops accompagné par
son vénérable maire et une délégation de
vénérable maître de la grande loge de
france sont à la porte du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vis dans le m à prendre place alors
rien
[Applaudissements]
et faire ficher de khéops prenez place à
vos plates 2
les chercheurs faire
vous ne recevrez pas d'autres
appellations parmi nous car vous êtes
ici dans un temps pour se pratiquer la
fraternité je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à notre appel et de nous avoir
témoigné ainsi votre sa bête
mes soeurs et frères prenez place
[Applaudissements]
enfin l'expert est ferme et décidée menu
veuillez vous rendre auprès du ciri
nissim grands maîtres et de la
délégation du conseil fédéral afin d
introduire dans le temple
[Applaudissements]
des surveillants des lieux se nourrir
dans une enceinte où l'agitation du
dehors des sourds et unités mais
deuxième surveillant que nous enseigne
de franc-maçonnerie l érable 550 une
passion de douane doublé et que nous
devons jouer toute chose avec
impartialité
conformément à la tradition des initiés
ils nous ont pressés des réformateurs
comment cette tradition est elle
parvenue jusqu'à lors de belles images
et penseur s'exprimer lors ses moyens et
possibilités infinies de sont les
symboles et philosophe de jadis dentaire
d'en chercher le sens profond voire
trouver la solution des problèmes se
posent elles se posent dans et hors des
dix buts en 10 à nous
mes soeurs aînées faire ce qui vient de
vous être dit vous aura fait comprendre
que la franc maçonnerie est une école à
laquelle sont admis ceux qui ont les
aptitudes voulu elle se distingue
toutefois d autres écoles car son
enseignement n'est pas formulée davance
ce qu'elle enseigne à l'initié c'est
l'art de penser et de découvrir par
lui-même les éléments de sa conviction
cet art est pour nous le grand art ouah
royal comme on l'appelait autrefois nous
sommes ses adeptes faible dans nos
moyens mais forme de notre sincérité
dans la recherche du vrai veuillez donc
mes soeurs et mes frères vous sentir en
confiance au milieu de nous n'ayant pas
la prétention de posséder la vérité dont
la poursuite et notre constante
préoccupation
nous nous garderons bien de vous imposer
un ordre quelconque nous vous
présenterons des idées il vous y
réfléchirez par vous même afin de vous
former votre propre jugement
[Applaudissements]
vénérable mais d'une délégation du
conseil fédéral
conduite par le sérénissime grand maître
de la grande loge de france
mes soeurs et mes frères nous allons
recevoir maintenant le civil s'il faut
mettre de la grande loge de france
accompagné d'une délégation au conseil
fédéral
veuillez vous lever données l'entrée du
temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
m
respectant le frein conseillers fédéraux
c'est avec une grande joie que les
frères de la respectable rusk et or si
vous accueille
nous sommes très sensibles à l'honneur
une fête en venant prendre part à nos
travaux je vous invite à monter à
lorient et vos places
[Applaudissements]
oui
mais cela laisse faire les fondations se
réunissent dans le secret de la mort
pour travailler à la recherche de la
vérité pour le bonheur de l'humanité
il arrive qu'une loge entre ouvre ses
portes pour donner au monde extérieur
une idée du sérieux des travaux qui s'y
rend complice élever ses vues élargir le
champ sa pensée et peut-être gagner son
plein celui qui s'adresse à vous
aujourd'hui n'est ni le grand médecin
pierre simon ni le sociologue célèbre ni
l'auteur connu de nombreux ouvrages ni
mail l'homme politique à qui pourtant
nous devons beaucoup
c'est le franc-maçon pierre cimon
démocratiquement élu devant maître de
cette obédience par ses frères de la
grande loge de france sérénissime grand
maître de la parole pour ta conférence
la franc maçonnerie laboratoires
associés
le président mes frères les soeurs
comment se fait-il que en 1975 les temps
modernes 7 millions de francs maçons
existe et parcourt le monde
chacune des grandes entreprises
généreuses et belle grands qui ont
marqué l'humanité a souvent été
accompagné par l'esprit sinon par le
franc maçon lui même me rappellerai ici
devant vous d'une en créant la croix
rouge rappelle régis ci devant vous
l'esprit de saint louis qui était le nom
de l'avion que les bergs avec lequel il
baird a traversé l'atlantique et qui
était ce motif
le nom de soeur jumelle qui avait en
quelque sorte de contribuer à l'achat
d'avions pour montrer que leurs deux
mineurs le destin était susceptible de
franchir atlantique
enfin est-ce le premier homme à avoir
mis les pieds sur la lune
paul green et qui avait afin qu'elles
soient ceux ci à l'image la bannière
étoilée associés jure
bull le patch de ce logement r pourquoi
front national était le laboratoire de
la société
et bien simplement parce que ceux qui
viennent frapper à la porte de notre
temple proviennent de toutes les couches
sociales
ils procèdent de toutes les équipes et
vous verrez ainsi totalement dessus
dépend à la fois le ministre le concerne
le marchand étudiants l'intellectuel le
manuel tous se sont dépouillés de leurs
cartes de visite avant d'entrer dans le
temple et sont assis sur ses enfants en
une comme une réflexion
connaissez vous d'autres sociétés dans
laquelle il vous est possible
aujourd'hui de mou façonné n'ont pas
leur échapper à la société occidentale
que nous avons nous-mêmes forget qui
nous conditionnent mais au contraire
pour pouvoir aussi intégré pour ne pas
être ballotté comme la feuille aux
enfants mais au contraire pour nous y
sentir parfaitement à l'aise et qui plus
est pour avoir pris sur
evènement pour pouvoir participer et
procédés de l'événement combien d'entre
nous vivent la véritable vie qu'ils ont
souhaité vivre un jour combien d'entre
vous n'ont pas un matin en se regardant
dans la glace relevé combien d'entre
vous ne se sont pas un jour interrogé en
vision je souhaiterais vivre moi aussi
la véritable identité je me serais donné
je souhaite former ma propre personne
l'accouchement qui fut le mien n'a pas
forcément accouché de la personne qui
dit elle alors l'homme aura la
possibilité d'opérer lui même ses
propres choix et c'est ce qu'a opération
ce nouvel accouchement cette espèce
d'autobild tic
cet accouchement concorde et les soit
belle il va pouvoir me permettre
d'accéder à la livrée ce jour-là il
viendra frapper à la porte du temple et
demandera la ligue 1 mais tout compte
fait c'est un c'est un pilier du monde
du monde tel qu'il est pour vous ils
font partie du système absolument bien
tapisserie est un plan dhr du xviie
siècle et c'est la plus vieille
tapisserie qui véhicule le mythe
maçonniques en son centre l'on voit
hiram hiram qui est pour les francs
maçons le maître et il manie ce qui est
le symbole essentiel du franc-maçon le
compas c'est avec ce compaq il montre au
roi salomon qui lui a commandé
l'édification du temple celui là même
que nous construisons symboliquement ce
qui est important c'est que cette
tapisserie rapporte en même temps ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui les trois grades de
la franc maçonnerie
l'apprenti le compagnon et lemaitre que
l'on voit ici travailler chacun selon
ses aptitudes c'est à dire du passage de
l'éclair au compas enfin la croix de
malte qui brise les grecs ici montre que
c'est l'ordre de malte qui au départ
avait été l'instigateur de cette
tapisserie
[Musique]
si la légende fait des francs maçons les
héritiers des maîtres d'oeuvre égyptien
hébreu et babyloniens tout le monde
s'accorde pour reconnaître la filiation
directe existant entre la franc
maçonnerie moderne dite spéculative et
la maçonnerie des bâtisseurs du moyen
âge dit maçonnerie opératif les maçons
bâtisseurs des églises et des
cathédrales formèrent très vite un
métier à part les secrets professionnels
de l'art de bâtir étaient nombreux et
teinté de symbolisme sol les maîtres
maçons y accéder dès le douzième siècle
les maçons constituèrent un franc métier
ils devinrent des francs-maçons francs
signifiant libre et indépendant des
juridictions seigneurial
au 12e siècle aussi les templiers ont
besoin des maîtres maçons pour édifier
leur citadelle mais personne ne portera
jamais la preuve que les templiers on
peut transmettre aux fraternité
maçonnique les secrets initiatique qui
leur furent divulgué pendant les
croisades par les sectes de palestine
ces associations de francs maçons se
généralise et sont très actives en
france et dans toute l'europe jusqu'à la
fin du xvème siècle puis elles
disparaissent seule l'angleterre à la
fin du xvième siècle possède encore des
loges organisée selon la tradition
médiévale
mais peu à peu les constructeurs cèdent
la place à des nobles des prêtres ou des
bourgeois ce sont les maçons accepté et
la maçonnerie opérative se transforme
ainsi en maçonnerie spéculative ou
philosophique
le symbolisme et les méthodes des maçons
ne sont plus alors utilisé pour
construire un temple de pierre mais un
temple spirituel l'initiation à la
construction devient purement symbolique
le 24 juin 1717 quatre loges de londres
c'est riche en grandes loges mais peu
après cette grande loge adopte les
constitutions d'anderson un texte qui
codifiant les anciens devoirs maçonnique
demeure aujourd'hui encore la charte
reconnu de la maçonnerie universel
des 1725 des loges de type anglais sont
installés en france
elles vont proliférer à telle enseigne
qu aux états généraux de 1789
les trois quarts des députés des trois
ordres sont maçons la révolution
disperse les frères la terreur l'effet
s'entre déchirer la franc maçonnerie ne
reprend vie que sous le premier empire
conseillé par les frères cambacérès et
kellerman napoléon 1er décide d'en faire
une institution officielle
la franc-maçonnerie se met alors au
garde à vous presque tous les régiments
de la grande armée possède une loge
militaire après 1815 la franc-maçonnerie
se rallie au bourbeau révolution de 48
plusieurs membres du grand orient siège
au gouvernement provisoire
les frères crémieux louis blanc et
garnier pagès
dès son arrivée au pouvoir napoléon iii
comme autrefois son oncle transforme la
maçonnerie en instrument docile du
pouvoir
la révolution du 4 septembre 1870 amène
au pouvoir un gouvernement dont neuf
membres sur 11 sont maçons les plus
célèbres gambetta arago jules favre
jules ferry la commune éclater comme
toujours les maçons se partagent dans
les deux camps ennemis de nombreux
maçons se bat aux côtés des communards
certains même un siège au comité central
de la commune
parmi eux jules vallès camélinat
jean-baptiste-clément crémieux et
raspail beaucoup de maçon communards
durant la répression seront fusillés
emprisonnés ou déportés les survivants
seront désavoué par les hauts
responsables du grand orient
les débuts de la troisième république
voit désormais une petite bourgeoisie
industrieuse volontiers anti clérical
afflué dans les loges
la maçonnerie s'engage aussi dans la
lutte politique
l'anticléricalisme se déchaîne avec le
frère émile combes pendant 30 années à
partir de 1901 l'histoire du grand
orient et du parti radical vont se mêler
intimement
c'est l'âge d'or de la république des
députés et des ministres masson ce qui
fera dire plus tard la franc maçonnerie
a constitué le score est invisible de la
république
en effet de 1873 à 1931 la république
connaît six chefs d'état masson 1933 la
sphère stavisky les noms de maçon
célèbres sont jetés en pâture à
l'opinion publique
les forces de droite les fascistes
dénonce le soi disant complot
judéo-maçonnique 1940 les adversaires
les plus farouches de la maçonnerie se
retrouve au sein du gouvernement de
vichy pétain ordonne la dissolution des
loges c'est la chasse aux maçons ou
petit palais et bien de s'ouvrir
l'exposition au masonic qui jette la
lumière sur la curieuse et mystérieuse
mise en scène établi par les francs
maçons qui prétendait ainsi à
impressionner leurs adeptes
on ne peut que s'étonner et sourire
aussi de constater que ces rites d'un
autre âge et plus à notre époque faire
l'objet de telles crédulité bon bien de
solennel pontife de la politique
restèrent dans cette cellule appelée
chambre de réflexion et par et
d'ornement macabre
ou bien revêtir le tablier maçonnique ou
pas certes à leur cou ses sautoirs rodez
de signes cabalistiques symbole de leur
puissance secrète
aujourd'hui anéanti donc voilà un bon
droit
[Musique]
la masseuse si l'os est tellement hélas
plongée dans les ténèbres dans quelques
pays européens
la vocation maçonnique exige que le bon
fonctionnement d'une loge maçonnique
puisse se faire librement
et cela n'est possible que dans un pays
libéral des régimes totalitaires
c'était le tour est le premier souci du
gouvernement a été la fermeture des
loges maçonniques partout dans le monde
quel que soit le régime politique existe
nous avons des loges maçonniques connus
ou inconnus
les adversaires et les ennemis de la
maçonnerie lyon principalement reproché
à vent de la dissoudre de s'être immiscé
dans la vie politique du pays
trente ans après la libération le
sénateur henri caillavet épaules
anxionnat ancien ministre et précédent
grand maître du grand orient font le
point les parlementaires ont décidé de
se regrouper dans une feinte ternel
c'est à dire que l'ensemble des députés
feraient massot des sénateurs fera
massot et des membres du conseil
économique fera massot se réunissent
afin de traiter en commun d'un certain
nombre de problèmes législatifs les
documents elles qui sont à notre
disposition sont examinés chaque mois ce
qui nous concerne avec le prisme notre
jugement maçonnique
oui langois nous efforçons de faire
aboutir des amendements qui sont communs
et c'est ainsi que nous avons des
rapports permanent avec les hauts
fonctionnaires qui peuvent en
leurs qualités de maçon nous accorder le
bénéfice de la réflexion et en retour
nous mêmes leur faisons part de nos
observations
donc on peut dire qu'il ya une
corrélation directe entre les travaux en
loges et les problèmes des battues dans
les assemblées élues
c'est d'évidence avons tous été rappelé
des tendances orient après la commune
par ce choc moral profond qui montrait
qu'il fallait absolument modifié de fond
en comble la condition ouvrière et les
transformations du code du travail qui
ont suivi on s'adore régime des travaux
masson et surtout donations que tu as
connu et qui arthur groussier qui était
pendant près de cinquante ans par la loi
socialiste à paris comme nous sommes au
gouvernement
nous sommes bien évidemment responsables
de politiques français et nous ne sommes
pas des maçons mais dans notre conduite
d'hommes à l'évidence nous sommes
menacés bien et nous tentons d'infléchir
les décisions en fonction de cet idéal
maçonnique auxquels nous sommes attachés
les 45000 masson français sont répartis
inégalement en cette obédience donc
trois ont un rôle primordial
le grand orient de france a pour lui la
légitimité historique est aussi le plus
grand nombre de maçons ils réclament 23
mille membres répartis en 4 139
disséminés à travers la france les
départements d'outre-mer les ex colonie
française la grande loge française
compte environ 11 mille adhérents et 245
loge elle aussi répartie sur le
territoire national et les pays
d'outre-mer la grande loge nationale
française fondée en 1913 revendique 5000
membres et 120 loge qu'elle administre
en france et en afrique
elle est la seule obédience française
reconnue par la grande loge unie
d'angleterre ce qui fait d'elle une
puissance maçonnique régulière or aux
yeux des autres grandes loges du monde
la femme est aussi présente en
maçonnerie
même si cela irrite certains maçons il
existe une obédience mixte le droit
humain qui regroupe quatre mille hommes
et femmes travaillant ensemble en loge
d'autre part depuis 1945 fonctionne une
grande loge féminine de france dont les
3000 membres uniquement du sexe féminin
se sont donné pour but de créer un
meilleur équilibre entre les droits et
les devoirs de l'homme et ceux de la
femme
[Musique]
mes soeurs il est l'heure d'ouvrir les
travaux venez m'aider à préparer le
temple
[Musique]
je
metteur je voudrais essayer la musique
vous voulez me dire son l'entente fond
du temple
[Musique]
le mes soeurs
je crois que tu tes pairs vous avez
pensé aux boules nous avons un vote pour
une admission ce soir regagnons les
parties pour mettre vos décors
[Musique]
en payant un certain nombre de rythme et
enfin je pense que ça devait tomber un
peu en désuétude des rites qui sont
assez assez compliqué au départ enfin
qu'ils étaient des rites d'initiation
quoi comme dans puisque la maçonnerie
est héritée de est hérité de deux
système corporatif dans l'ancien régime
par conséquent il y avait toute sorte de
rite d'initiation me fâcher plus du tout
si c'est pas tombé en désuétude tout ça
[Musique]
ce temple numéro un du conte orient de
france porte le nom d'un franc-maçon
illustre arthur groussier comme tous les
temples de notre obédience
il rappelle le temple de salomon de
jérusalem et porte les symboles
principaux de la franc maçonnerie
il est matériellement fermés au monde
extérieur sans ouverture que les portes
cet isolement symbolise la volonté des
francsmaçons de rester à l'écart des
passions du monde passion qui engendre
non seulement l'intolérance mais
aboutissent à la violence les colonnes
sont un élément essentiel de
l'architecturé classique le premier
symbole qu'on petit voir c'est la
fonction de soutien de l'édifice
garantie d'existence et de pérennité
la colonne apparaît dans l' architecture
comme un élément de liaison entre le
monde d'en haut et le monde d'en bas
entre les ténèbres et la lumière sur la
colonne du midi la lettre b qui est
l'initiale du nom de bose qui signifie
la force sur la colonne du nord le la
lettre j initiale de yakine qui
représente la sagesse la beauté les
autres symboles sont aussi importants
la bible est est supprimé et remplacé
par l'équerré compagnie au dessus le
buste de la république
décoré du bandeau du décor maçonnique
les maçons français travaillent sont 88
principaux un rythme à sonic est un
ensemble de règles fixant le cérémonial
des initiations et des délibérations
dans les loges
ce tableau représente en un symbole tout
ce que doit percevoir l'initié en
quelque sorte on a arraché de la matière
ce qui sont ces instruments de mesure
immédiatement perceptible qui font que
l'homme dispose d'une intelligence et
que voit-il le fond du miroir laisse
apparaître lui même sa propre image mais
avec une dimension complémentaire qui
est celle de l'initier c'est à dire en
quelque sorte qu une vie nouvelle va se
dessiner devant lui
[Musique]
les symboles et les rituels maçonniques
ont donné à des artistes naïfs
l'occasion d'exprimer leur croyance en
images souvent surprenantes
[Musique]
[Rires]
les outils des bâtisseurs de cathédrales
ayant perdu leur fonction initiale
prennent dans la maçonnerie moderne des
valeur de symbole différentes leurs
significations sont parfois
complémentaires par exemple le conte
pape symboliser la mesure dans la
recherche ou la faculté de jugement
les guerres peut signifier la rectitude
dans l'action ou l'équité et la justice
cet objet précieux est un maillet masse
ionique qui symbolise entre les mains
d'un vénérable de loges la puissance est
l'autorité qui là pour diriger ses
frères dans la loge voilà une pierre
c'est la pierre brute elle figure une
pierre vivante et elle symbolise le
récipiendaire qui pour la rendre
publique devra l'affiner
c'est sa propre pierre alors voici cette
pierre elle est rendue publique les
terrains du lys elle est aidée grossi
par le maçon qui est entré en maçonnerie
qui est une pierre cubique et
aujourd'hui il atteint à la libre
disposition de ses moyens maçonnique qui
lui permettent de s'affirmer
définitivement comme un franc maçon
comme un maître maçon
chaque année au mois de juin
les maçons des diverses obédiences se
réunissent à fresnes dans le val d'oise
pour célébrer la saint jean d'été
la fête a lieu chez josé laval le maçon
opératif qui bâtit des temps c'est
l'occasion d'une tenue blanche ouverte
et en même temps une fête populaire
l'embrasement d'un monceau de fagots de
15 mètres de haut précède une cérémonie
où l'on glorifie la lumière un symbole
capitale de la maçonnerie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le temple en plein air de presles et
garder à son entrée par un adam rouge et
unef noir ces deux statues symbolise les
deux colonnes que l'on retrouve à
l'entrée de tout temple maçonnique
elle représente la force et la beauté
ont célébré ensemble comme une force est
la vôtre et war vous venez vous frappera
moore surveillants dans la loge de
saint-jean-de-jérusalem vénérable maître
pour 10 élèves des temples à la vertu et
on y cause de cachou pour lévis à des
bateaux
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bref rien n'est fermé pour des
cérémonies veuillez vous rendre à la
porte du temple pour y accueillir le
fait régner en maître de la grande loge
de pour accompagner plus gardner de
vénérables m
chat
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi voulez vous organisez la jia
plus courte de l'année
celui-ci grand maître c'est parce que
pendant des millénaires les premiers
hommes ont dès la tombée de la nuit
toujours attendues avec anxiété
l'apparition du soleil qui ne rendait
net et clair
la vision de nos ennemis possible se
félicite grand maître en faisant naître
une flamme dont la clarté frappera nos
yeux et éveillera en nous le souvenir de
la joie qu'ils éprouvaient nos ancêtres
quand dans les mauvais jours de l'hiver
la flamme remplaçait le soleil absent
cette flamme soit le symbole de
l'énergie que le soleil mais dans tous
les coeurs qu'elle soit le symbole de la
force sans laquelle la sagesse serait
désormais pour lutter contre toutes les
formes du mal sans la force
l'intelligence ne peut rien réaliser
que cette flamme soit le symbole de la
beauté la lumière du soleil rend belle
même les choses banales elle seule nous
permet de voir et de goûter les jeux des
couleurs rendons hommage à la beauté à
la beauté physique et surtout à la
beauté morale à la bonté à l'amour
fraternel de tous les hommes que le
soleil éclaire également et
indistinctement
mais ce qui distingue ce temple des
autres lieux fermés c'est qu'il est
orienté et non seulement dans le plan
mais encore dans l'espace le fait que
nous le soyons limite aignan onians bas
le fait que nous ne soyons pas limitée
dans le temps permet de nous rapprocher
des premiers âges de l'humanité
lorsque l'homme a célébré la lumière
fait tout à fait exceptionnel dans
l'histoire de son évolution
nous savons aujourd'hui la science nous
l'a confirmé que la vie est seul doute
la conjonction du feu et de l'eau et
c'est pourquoi ce soir
si nous recevons du ciel au lieu de la
vision de la voûte étoilée de l'eau il
s'agit d'un même et unique phénomène la
force la beauté la sagesse ce sont les
trois vertus qui font que la prom à
sonnerie toujours les associant réalise
sur terre l'harmonie qui fait tant
défaut à ceux qui ne savent opérer cette
vision triple car l'un sans l'autre ne
serait qu une inconscience de l'esprit
mes très chers frères mettraient
chercheurs avant de nous séparer nous
allons former une chaîne d'amour
vous allez tous masson et à me prendre
la main de vos voisins en trois ans vous
même vos bras lorsque la chaîne sera
fermée un grand courant d'harmonie
sera établi c'est dans la fraternité et
d'amitié et je ferai circuler les mots
de solstiss
mes frères les deux mots de solstiss
sont en train de circuler
je sais qu'ils reviendront comme à
l'accoutumée jusqu'à ce plateau juste et
parfait
les mots amour et bonté sont revenus au
plateau juste et parfait mes frères mes
soeurs
rompez la chaîne
m
[Applaudissements]
lorsque le candidat est accueilli à
l'entrée de la grande loge il est
introduit immédiatement dans le cabinet
de réflexion
c'est ce que nous appelons les preuves
de la terre et elle fait partie de
l'initiation
ce qui se rapporte à la théorie
platonicienne que la franc maçonnerie a
misé en symboles et en psycho dhr le
cabinet de réflexion n'est autre que
love philosophale des alchimistes la
caverne du monde
les trois principes airmédic figure avec
le soufre symbole de l'esprit le sel
symbole de la sagesse et de la science
le mercure emblème solaire il y assure
le cabinet de réflexion
l'inscription vitriol dont chaque lettre
et
la première d'une phrase tirée du latin
visite l'intérieur de la terre et en la
rectifiant tu trouveras lapiro culte
on distingue d'un crâne humain thiais le
symbolisme de la mort du profane au
préjugé vulgaire pour renaître à une vie
supérieure voilà l'explication qui est
donnée concernant le cabinet de
réflexion et que la première épreuve
avant que nous procédions à l'initiation
par les éléments ont reconduit le
candidat avant de recevoir la lumière
depuis le début du xviiie siècle les
rituels d'initiation aux trois premiers
grades maçonnique ont très peu changé
ici
l'initiation au grade de maître l'ont
fait revivre aux candidats à la maîtrise
le mythe de la mort et de la
réincarnation dirhams
est ce que vous reprochez aux maçons et
bien tous leurs petits salamalecs la
leur petit tablier leurs rites leurs
voeux tous les machins comme dans
l'église par contre c'est un peu dépassé
mais de toute façon à toute association
est utile ne serait ce que par leur
propre point de domme et donc d'opinion
des diaboliques
l'envié est là cette arche royal de
jérusalem a pour objet fondamentale la
recherche du mot perdu à la suite de la
mort du grand maître hiram l'arche royal
est la clé de voûte de l'édifice
maçonnique
les trois excellents grand principaux du
grand chapitre de la sainte arche royal
de jérusalem pour la france
oh dieu omnipotent omniscient et
omniprésent pour qui tous les coeurs
sont à découvert tous les désirs connu à
qui il se crée des cachets vérifie les
pensées de nos coeurs afin que nous
puissions glorifier dignement trop salon
qu'il en serait ainsi
[Musique]
nous sommes réunis autour de ton
cercueil pour te rendre un dernier
hommage fraternel par ta disparition
tu as brisé notre chaîne d'union tout à
l'heure et notre frère gênera de
remplacer pour continuer d'oeuvre
maçonnique
le soir de tonnes initiation lorsque tu
étais plonger dans la solitude du
cabinet de réflexion nous avons montré
l'image de la mort du a rédigé son
testament philosophique
aujourd'hui tout achemine vers un monde
nouveau
mystérieuse et inconnue ou qui recevra
l'ultime initiation en quittant qui nous
laisse ta femme et tes enfants tu peux
partir dans la sérénité de l'esprit et
avec la paix dans l'âme
car grâce à tous les frères de notre
loge et à l'entr'aide fraternelle et à
l'orphelinat maçonnique ta femme et tes
enfants trouveront toujours parmi nous
la protection nécessaire afin que toute
absence ne soit pas durement ressenti et
maintenant mes très chers pères je vous
invite
avec moi 2
j'ai misé l'émission jugés mensongers
mis son génie sont mes frères je vous
invite à changer au cordeau avait tonné
voocorder parce que l'espérance demeure
une vocation maçonnique et j'invite les
frères vincent de venir intégrer dans
notre chaîne d'union universel et
remplacer notre très cher frère disparu
et nous allons tirer la 3e batterie
[Applaudissements]
espérer faire nos gardes
les l'espérance demeure une vocation
essentiellement maçonnique
et pas d'eau
au monde
g
chanel aux roms est vrai je n'ai qu'un
mot
à rhinau
ça
hu
[Musique]